and
welcome good evening good morning
depending on where you are in the world
my name is Stuart Creek I'll be your
host today
for our
webinar which is
on the postgraduate program in cyber
security from Simply learn
with modules from MIT and the EC Council
and this is a one hour webinar which
allows time for your questions at the
end
um I'll beat the Live host today we will
have some segments that were
pre-recorded from an earlier uh
presentation of this webinar in
September so please be aware of that and
we'll get started
um in the pre-recorded segments we'll
hear from William Bailey who is a noted
cyber security expert previously the VP
of information security for a financial
institution consultant with experience
across a wide range of Industries more
than 20 years of experience in the
sector and involved with chapter Boards
of the
regulating bodies and associations for
information security so
we'll hear from him in a little bit but
we're talking about cyber security
careers we'll be talking about what this
program offers you
and how it gets you job ready in six
months then we'll talk about how you can
enroll and I'll take some of your
questions
and
before we get to our first poll
going to
share a pre-recorded segment that I did
with
bill in September
ly
foreign
ERS in cyber security why is cyber
security so important
so much of our lives
are in the
distance
is
government
um this has gotten right now where you
because of instead of things and mobile
applications
you're gonna
almost constant risk
personally
every aspect that we're working
um what are your thoughts about that you
know
last year
now 2021 uh pricewaterhousecoopers uh
PWC they came out with this uh report
the survey in this subsequent report I
don't think you could do anything about
a computer
they don't even want you to
did you want to like I went to a
conference
last Friday
they don't even have a cashier at the
parking lot parking garage or anything
you have to reserve your your parking
and dance you have to do it via the
website you have to give them a credit
card number it's all online and the bus
system actually yeah where I went it's
all they actually don't want that
incentives perhaps
you know do you want to pay four dollars
to take the bus and you want to pay two
dollars
I have their app on my phone and it
everything is uh
you know it's electronic you know it's
it's the PC app it's a web app it's a
mobile app
[Music]
s
to be about my most recent
trip to Hawaii where I had pre-reserved
a parking place at our local airport you
had to get in keep a QR code on your
phone
well this is my email but for some
reason I couldn't access my email from
my phone and so I had to stop the car
pull it to the side
get into my laptop computer hope that I
had connectivity
um and access my email to get that QR
code so this was a
expected cyber security
anybody
I'm hearing I'm seeing in the chat that
people aren't hearing this correctly
and I am going to uh stop using the
pre-recorded video and I'm going to just
move on uh and cover that information
directly
so please uh bear with me as I did the
narration
um apologize for the technical
difficulties
I don't know what the audio problem was
but I will
uh take over from that so
moment
again my apologies I will
repair the problem here
and
here we go
thank you
so my apologies for the audio issues uh
you're playing a pre-recorded segment
but apparently we're not getting the
audio from that and I will stop playing
the pre-reported segment because it
doesn't help you without the audio and
I'll just uh mention
what this slide tells us the
pricewaterhousecooper 2021 digital trust
survey
looked at
cisos and cios the Chief Information
security officers and the Chief
Information officers uh from major
organizations
and found that they didn't feel like
they were ready to deal with cyber
security fully half or more of them said
they haven't
really addressed all the risks
associated with the issues that came up
during the pandemic of remote work uh
digital transformation into the digital
world Cloud adoption
um because in the
period starting in 2020 the requirements
of the pandemic
forced companies to go to the
remote work work from home
model
and
to threat
um
the threat surface
of what we were um looking at
has changed dramatically that surface is
all the potential points of attack for
an organization
or cyber security
and because so much more of
the work of the organization was exposed
outside of the organization's own four
walls
with remote work work from home people
using personal devices uh as their
workstations
suddenly the challenge of cyber security
extremely
uh
Brave
mushroomed from what it was before
there's a quote I saw from a
um
Venture Capital firm
early on in the pandemic quote was if
they had told us we needed to transfer
everyone to work from home
we would have told our bosses that it
took it would take six months and 10
million dollars when it happened
we did it in three days with no budget
and the downside of that
flexibility and Agility is
that within three days I know no budget
they were able to get people working
from home but they weren't able to
secure
those
connections to home based work
so this is a huge area of concern
for industry it's a huge area concern
for us in our personal lives none of us
wants to be hacked or have our account
information stolen from our banks or
personal information compromised
and this is only getting bigger as the
internet of things makes more of our
world digital and therefore subject to
cyber security threats and as mobile
applications make more of our daily
lives
subject to those same threats so
this is why this area is so important
apologize again we're not going to be
able to hear from bill today because
difficulties with the um
audio but I will try to do my best to
fill in for what he was saying
the cyber security skills that you need
to be
apply in different roles in industry
secure applications and systems
give you a lot of different career
opportunities
you can be a secure security
infrastructure specialist and advise
companies are designed for companies the
security
systems that protect their
information you can become a network
security consultant and talk to them
about the implications of what happens
Network transactions uh you can be a
general security analyst you can be an
application security analyst and look at
vulnerability points of particular
software applications
let's look at Cloud security Architects
design security
systems and protocols for cloud-based
operations
you can be the blue team member who
looks at potential
vectors of threat how to defend against
them you can be a red team member or a
white hat hacker does
penetration testing to look at
points of vulnerability for an
organization and attempt to break that
security for them to show them where
they're vulnerable can be a software
developer for cyber security tools you
can be an analyst of malware
you can be a threat Hunter
from both ends looking for where threats
are originating from inside and outside
the organization so all of these
potential roles are career opportunities
for you
um
you need up-to-date
skills they enter any of these roles and
in this type of work you need to be able
to understand all the different aspects
so that if you specialize in a
particular area for example cloud
computing
you understand how that interacts with
application security network security
all the other aspects and can coordinate
your work the work of other specialists
so you need to understand infrastructure
security and application security you
need to understand how malware and
ransomware work you need to understand
the principles of cryptography which are
used in securing systems uh you need to
understand the principles and how to do
ethical hacking and threat hunting web
application penetration testing and all
of these give you a well-rounded
foundation for a cyber security career
so at this point I am going to ask you
this first question
just take me a second to
bring up the hole
holy
the first poll question is
why have you not yet
engaged in a program to become a cyber
security professional
holes in progress
you can answer with one two three or all
four of the answers
but what are the factors that have
stopped you so far
from enrolling in a program of this type
and becoming a cyber security
professional
I'll close the pole in about 10 seconds
here
so about half of our audience says that
you don't
feel that you found a program that will
give you practical experience that you
can demonstrate
um job Readiness to employers
of course the other
answers some of you answered each of
those other areas so I'll address
how this program
postgraduate program in cyber security
from Simply learned
um
addresses those
concerns
the
QR code on the screen by the way will
take you to the program page but I'll
share that later
this is the program with a comprehensive
curriculum industry aligned so that
we've heard from industry players what
they need
cyber Security Professionals to be able
to do for them
and we've built the curriculum around
that set of requirements
it's comprehensive so it covers all the
different skills and tools that we had
just talked about for job Readiness it's
delivered on the integrated
online platform
the learning management system allows
you to do all of your work online all of
your projects online and of course it
gives you access to the weekly online
live virtual classrooms these are live
sessions with your instructor and your
peers in in the class you get to
interact with the instructor ask
questions watch the instructor guide you
through the exercises and the concepts
that they're teaching that week
and you can interact with them and with
your peers to ask questions
clarification for anything you don't get
this will be a system allows them to the
instructor to share with you class files
find to you uh homework look at you look
at pre-recorded video content
um
or preparation for the following weeks
class or for follow up on this week's
class
and
um
it allows you the learning management
system gives you 24 7 access that allows
you to
look at that material from anywhere you
are so on your desktop on your laptop
but also you've watched the pre-recorded
video content or class recordings to
catch up on something you missed
um watch this on your mobile device
these are available to you 24 7 along
with the support system that allows you
to ask the questions if you're stuck on
something at three o'clock in the
morning
and the answer or need some advice you
can contact 24 7 help desk
so
what you get from the program
is a certificate issued
by simply learn
certified also with
modules from MIT and EC Council
certify their portion of the program and
also a
certificate from mit's Schwartzman
College of computing that you have
completed this program so both of these
are your documentary proof that you can
show off to employers that yes you have
done the work you are job ready as
certified by simply learning and by MIT
along the way you're going to do
uh 35 exercises 10 projects
a Capstone project that will be your
final project for the course and ties
together all of your skills and you'll
have the ability to take master classes
with MIT instructors so
the intra on this program you only need
a bachelor's degree with 50 marks or
better at the GPA of 2.0 or above
and do not have to have work experience
although it's a good thing to have
for preparation for this course you also
don't have to be from a programming
background because you will get the
skills you need to succeed in this
course through the program itself so
it's open pretty much to everybody who's
got a bachelor's degree
and did
at least all write in school
so with that I'm going to ask of the
second poll question second poll
question is how much experience do you
happen to have in the workplace and not
necessarily in cyber security but just
in general
in the Working World so I'll leave that
open for
a while and let you answer those
questions
and I'm watching the answers come in
we'll close the poll in about 10 seconds
and
the about half of the audience has less
than two years of experience so you're
fairly new in the workforce however
there's a number of people almost a
third who have more than 10 years of
experience and then people in the
intermediate ranges as well so uh broad
range of experience in the audience and
this program is ideal
help all of you whether you're new to
the workforce or whether you are
pivoting into cyber security from some
other area or want to add cyber security
skills
to
your toolkit for some other part of
some other area of work
let's talk about how this program
prepares you and this time I am going to
go back to the pre-recorded material but
I'm not going to rely on the audio so
please bear with me for a moment while I
start that
and again
avoiding the audio problem I will
narrate the video
so
Captain thank you for being here you
know Bill okay
so this is the demonstration
the online boot camp
hold on for just a moment here
all right
so
we're going to show the learning
management system and this is the login
screen and
will take you into your account
and
this is uh going to be delivered
class sessions will be delivered through
zoom and not WebEx we're transitioning
to zoom we're doing that for our
webinars as well so you won't have some
of the same issues about audio
uh again I apologize for today's issues
but we'll be looking at um
how this helps you the
one of the things Bill pointed out was
he was on a Macintosh platform Apple
Macintosh and apple required him to do a
operating system upgrade just before
this class and so he's mentioning that
one of the reasons that Apple requires
you to do upgrades and now on Windows 11
and all those
wonderful things is that
cyber security
factors in operating systems have become
vitally important that's why you need to
be
constantly upgrading your software so
here's the opening screen of the
learning management system and it
provides you with your full
curriculum path so as Bill Scrolls
through this he'll show you that you get
into the the curriculum path that will
show you what classes are in the overall
program and
he's scrolling through these eight
modules
and you do them in a sequence you start
off with an introductory program that
lets you unlock the first class and then
you go into
each module sequence
as you complete it you unlock access
that next course
and this lets you go through this
curriculum in an orderly fashion so that
each course gives you the tools to
succeed in the next course and it builds
up your skills in a particular
sequence
so that they accumulate over time
by the time you finish the final course
you're ready to do the Capstone project
which demonstrates your whole range of
skills so along the way you do earn
certain certificates
um so for example in
the ceh or the top TI Security Plus you
have the ability then to take those
certification courses
from the certifying bodies in some
instances the
certifying test
vouchers provided so you don't have to
pay that extra
and this allows you to
get additional
documentary proof of your ability
so in this particular case you start off
with the introduction cyber security
and again as you finish the course
it then allows you to access and start
the next course so it's going to take
you in a sequence that's going to kind
of regulate your progress through the
program
so that you can't skip ahead too far and
you stay on path with your instructor
and with your cohort of fellow students
and that way we help you succeed in the
best possible way
so
he's showing the
various courses that comprise the
curriculum
you go into
um
the hacking mindset and how to do
penetration testing then you go into
um
the policy and
general principles of cyber security
governance
along the way you're building up this
set of
different uh capabilities
now here he's showing the pre-recorded
video content of some of the
modules that you can watch
self-paced to prepare you for each
upcoming class so as part of each course
there's going to be some content that
you'll do on your own
anytime during the week leading up to
the next week's classes you don't have
to do it at a particular time of day you
can do it anywhere you want and
that gives you the flexibility to do
this program even if you're a working
professional so
he's showing the interface that allows
you to choose the particular module or
content that you want to look at
and
you can go into your class
calendar happens he's not actually a
student he's an instructor so he doesn't
have his Uh current class curriculum or
a calendar there but you will and you'll
be able also to see recordings of your
past classes so there's a requirement to
attend a certain number of classes live
in order to
pass the program
but if you do miss one or two you'll be
able to catch up on those by looking at
these recordings through the
test class menu here
and
again you'll also be able to interact
with your instructor between Class
periods during the week you can email
them
and interact with your peers on the
community bulletin board set up for
students for your your course for your
program be able to do that as well
let's move on here
you'll also take assessments
at the end of each course so you'll be
able to take a test
demonstrate that you've succeeded uh in
learning the content of the course and
you will unlock the certificate for that
course
so
the course carries a mini certificate
not the proof of completion of the
program but it shows that you're one
step closer to completing the program
and as you complete the coursework and
the assessments for each of those
courses in the program
you unlock a certificate that gives you
then access to the next module
and then finally you'll be able to
unlock
the certificate for the full program so
once you have completed all the classes
on the
curriculum list
you'll
do the Capstone project submit it once
it's
um
evaluated you'll then be able to unlock
your full
program certificate so here's a menu
that's showing
this individual's certificates
that they've earned for each of the
courses so far
and which ones they've unlocked and that
will take them to the final
certificate for the program that's your
proof of completion that's what you show
off to potential employers
that's how you get your next job so
you'll also have as bill is mentioning
here the
community
tab that takes you to the bulletin board
to talk to fellow students ask them for
help what they did on their
latest they just exercise compare notes
um
and also your ability to instruct
interact with your instructor
so
that
is the overview of the
learning management system
now we'll talk about
the curriculum itself
so the the program has four core modules
with the
orientation sessions before and the
Capstone project after so you started
off with your orientation session which
gets you
um
aligned to how to use the lending
management system
what to expect in terms of class
schedules and the work that you'll be
required to do
then you move into your first module
which talks about designing systems that
provide cyber security
once you've completed that you move on
to developing a hacker mindset
ability to look at how hackers would
attack a system so that you can
understand where to defend from
and that's a
very valuable
way of thinking as you look at how the
Predator would come in and try to Prey
Upon your system
that gives you an idea of where you need
to protect against vulnerabilities
then you learn how to create the overall
security
posture the overall security policy for
your particular organization
um and how you would defend it
organization against
cyber security threats internal and
external
and the last module talks about policy
and technology and governance
General
environment that cyber security has to
operate under because
today's world many agencies of public
and private
have set up standards that organizations
have to follow
insurers will set up standards for cyber
security in order
Grant coverage to organizations you'll
have government bodies that will require
certain cyber security
measures be taken to protect
consumer or organizational information
so all of these things are things you
need to know to be able to operate
cyber security sector
and finally the Capstone project this is
a three to four week project done under
the mentorship of one of your
instructors and that shows that you have
the capability to solve a real world
industry problem
along the way you can take the cyber
security master classes from MIT
instructors these are electives so you
don't have to take them but if you have
the time and the inclination they are
included in the program cost
strongly recommend that you do back to
10 months
you'll be exposed to a number of
different tools platforms
libraries things that you will use in
the work of cyber security
so that when you create your resume
update it from the end of this program
you'll be able to list
the various tools that you've used in
the program with the confidence being
able to say I have not only know what
they are but I've used them I'll be able
to show you examples of how I use them
so
that's a very valuable
very powerful way
up
your curriculum Vita your resume
again the Capstone project is
a real life business scenario where
you're told
a particular company in a certain
industry how would you address this
cyber security problem you have to
secure their transactions or do you have
to cure their Cloud
environment and you build the solution
and you meet with your instructor weekly
over a three to four week period and
they help you stay on track not get
attracted into dead ends and help you
get to the end of the project with
something that
they can approve as your final project
in the program but also something that
is in your portfolio permanently that
you can show off the potential employers
so that you'll be able to say
here's a the way I solved this problem
where I built the solution and you can
inspect that and see the kind of work
that I would do for you if I take this
job so
this is a very rigorous and
in depth
project that gives you and potential
employers confidence in your cyber
security skills and abilities
MIT
master classes are taught by Professor
Nikolai sultivic
and it's in the
Department of electrical engineering
computer science at MIT
industry expert
entrepreneur and he's well positioned to
to give you a background on what
industry requires in cyber security so
very proud to have him as part of this
program
ideal candidates for this program I
mentioned it covers the Spectrum entry
level
folks the people in the poll who said
that they had two or less years of
working experience
these are people
who can take this program as a launching
point for a career
if you're already a professional in
digital technology or if you're a
manager
this program allows you to broaden your
capabilities understand cyber security
be able to apply it in your existing
career
let you move forward or let you pivot
into cyber security if you want to
change your career path
so at this point I will ask the next
question
very straightforward question so
oops
based on what you've heard so far today
what we've shown you are you interested
in enrolling in this program
I'll give you about 15 seconds to answer
that
close the poll in five
and here uh the results
there we go
uh just shy of 90 of our audience is
interested in enrolling in the program
just which is fantastic
and that gives me the opportunity to
tell you how to do that
so enrolling in the program is
straightforward
three steps the first step is to email
us at ask us at simplylearn.net
contact our learning Consultants through
that email address
they will go over with you the
application process
what you need to submit to show that you
have your required bachelor's degree
and any type of assessment
will do to show what level of Readiness
you have for the technical parts of the
program
and asset review
then they will send you an admission
letter offered by email
and you can join the program
the next cohort of the program starts in
January so
about six weeks from now there will be a
welcome session uh the classes then
we'll start right after that in February
and the classes be four hours each day
on the weekends so for our Saturday for
our Sunday
um so that's part of your commitment to
show up for those every week and then of
course your your homework or other
projects in between Class sessions
and the price of this program
either for U.S candidates and rest of
the world outside of India uh three
thousand dollars
less which we've been Finance as low as
700 207
270 per month
uh if you're in India the price is one
block forty thousand and
again finance that no interest financing
46 48 a month to be clear the financing
does extend until the fall fee is paid
off not just for the six months you're
in the program so if you choose the
financing option you do have the
obligation until then bully paid
um again contact us at ask us at simply
learn.net and I'll put that into the
chat as I
take some of your questions here
so apologizing again for the audio
issues that kept us from hearing
bill
and
Katie blooming would like to look at the
fundamental skill set page and I can do
that just
and uh
I'll just go ahead and show that page
again
so I'll clarify for you
we're talking about the various skills
that you need
infrastructure Security application
security
uh analysis of
malware and ransomware
uh the ethical hacking aspects threat
hunting
and penetration testing and then of
course cryptography is another
aspect of that so
those are the e-skill I hope that helps
the kalyani makes an observation you
need to have
uh
uh coding skills in cyber security but
you don't have to have them to enter
this program that's correct
um
come into the program without coding
skills you will be
given the training in what you need to
know in order to succeed
in the industry so
um
rashab asks if the course is free or if
there's financial aid the answer to that
is no it's not free we did show you the
pricing
and we do allow for your interest
financing however
um
we don't have bursaries or scholarships
available
what about placement so
simply learn
does provide certain
placement assistance
and
check on that for you but a number of
our programs both in India and the
United States we have
certain job assistance available
let me take a look see if that's
part of the program here
we are
and
all right
so we don't offer the full job
assistance Suite of services with this
program
but you can ask the learning counselors
about what job assistance is part of
this particular program so
um
what happens when one fails a module
that's a good question Daniel
if you fill a module you have the chance
to repeat it
so you are not going to automatically be
ejected from the program
we'll have the opportunity to go back
revise for that module and then
repeat it so that you can continue in
the program
um
what is the salary of an experienced
ethical hacker the best place to to get
the answer to that question is to go on
indeed or Glassdoor and
enter that job title into their search
bar and you will see
for your location what
both the typical and low end high-end
ranges of the salaries are for ethical
hackers
and we get jobs as freshers
the intention of the program is to get
you qualified so that you are job ready
and can go out and seek a job at the
entry level in cyber security
so um
partly uh mentions that the course is
not affordable to to
him and
um
there are other
individual courses not the complete
program that you can seek out but this
program is a paid program and it gives
you the live
instruction and assistance with the uh
foreign
structures which is why of course it
costs money
um
uh okay Obed is from South Africa would
like to know what the cost of the
program is in South African currency I
believe
if you enroll from South Africa which
you certainly can do oh God this is
available worldwide but it the price
will be denominated in US dollars so you
need the currency translation that
yourself
um
I believe
Canal you want to ask
people learning counselors that ask us
as simple as I've done that about the
ceh exam and whether it's certified
ethical hacker exam is part of the
program whether you've got a program a
voucher for that but please ask that
question
um
the program available for someone who
does not have a bachelor's degree
bachelor's degree is a requirement for
this program simple learning has other
courses available for people who have
not completed their bachelor's degree if
you are in process of completing your
bachelor's degree you can enroll in the
program so long as you will be graduated
from your bachelor's program
by the time you finish this program so
that's important to know
um
we will be sharing a recording of
this meeting uh
so we're sending a follow-up email out
to y'all
and
let me take a look at the other
questions coming in
terms of tools and techniques according
to oasp standard so I would ask that
question directly from the folks at the
the learning Consultants that ask us
that simply learn who will be able to go
into the details about the curriculum
down here
Denson asked great question I'm a
business business graduate specialized
in Commerce experience in the financial
sector and it has been in Broad risk
management this is an excellent course
for you uh Denson you understand
the commercial risk of fraud
and this is a way to add on to your
skill set the ability to detect and
prevent fiber broad cyber security
breaches so this is a great
a great program for that and of course
Financial financial sector is a main
user of cyber security Talent
when I was long the program the duration
of the program is six months
you need to be able to devote somewhere
between 10 and 15 hours a week to the
program because you'll have your weekend
classes and then the work in between
and
in being a cyber security expert
what is the most important thing you
have to do
the
the most important thing a cyber
security expert has to do is
to
uh
understand and communicate
the importance of cyber security in
mental threats to an organization
as one of the
greatest
aspect of cyber security threats is the
attitudes of people in an organization
if they don't take it seriously they are
become points of vulnerability
so one of the important aspects of a
cyber security expert one of those
important skills is communication
and um
education being able to
instruct both the management and the
employees of the organization as to why
cyber security is important and where
they need to be aware of
potential threats
both internally and externally well
that's the one pricing in the U.S of the
program is three thousand dollars
answering questions from Jonathan
and
I'll take this last question from arimo
who says he has front and coding
experience
is it necessary to have back-end coding
experience before one can study cyber
security or around in this program uh
you actually don't have to have coding
experience so having front-end coding
experience gives you a
perfectly valid Foundation to take this
program so
with that I'm going to
apologize to anybody whose questions I
didn't take but we'll move on to the
last
whole question for our presentation
today
don't mind me as I scroll through to
that last question
which is if you are interested in taking
this program
knowing what you know now
um
when would you
want to start
so are you interested in starting in
that cohort that begins in January
are you looking at something
maybe the one right after that one
uh is this something that you plan to do
further down the road
again we always say that if it's
something that will transform your
career and make your life better
um
may as well start now because
there's no reason to delay improving
your life
but this is again you understand
everyone's in a different situation
let's share this result
and almost 60 percent of the audience
wants to enroll either in the next
cohort or the one after that in February
March
um
and for everyone else recommend that you
as well contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
um
put that into the chat for you
and
here we go
here is the email address
and the link to our program page where
you can download
course brochure
and get any other questions that you
have answered by our learning
Consultants so
with that I want to thank you all for
being here today I want to apologize
again for the technical difficulties we
had
with the pre-recorded segments and
I hope that we can welcome you all into
the simply learned learning community so
contact us again at ask us at
simplylearn.net
and we will answer your questions and
help you get started
that concludes our webinar for today
thank you